.
NOW, WE ARE FIGHTING FOR
SURVIVAL.
>> Dana: IT HAS BEEN QUITE A
DAY.
WHAT IS THE LATEST?
>> Reporter: WE HAVE HEARD AIR
RAID SIRENS AGAIN THE UKRAINIAN
CAPITAL OF KYIV, AND EXPLOSIONS
IN THE DISTANCE.
IT'S NOT JUST THIS CITY.
THE SECOND LARGEST CITY IN
UKRAINE IS ALSO UNDER ATTACK
HEAVY RUSSIAN BOMBARDMENT.
A SQUARE IN THE CENTRAL PART OF
THE CITY WAS HIT, KILLING AT
LEAST SIX PEOPLE.
THE EVENT WAS CALLED "A WORK
RENT" AND IS CALLING THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY TO HOLD
THE RUSSIANS ACCOUNTABLE AND
RECONSIDER A NATO ALLIANCE
UKRAINE.
>> AS FAR AS A NO-FLY ZONE, IT
HAPPENS A LOT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT DRAGGING NATO
COUNTRIES INTO WAR.
THE TRUTH IS, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DRAGGED INTO WAR NOT BY UKRAINE,
BUT BY RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: THOUGH HE IS
BEING FROM THE BUNKER IN THE
UKRAINIAN CAPITAL OF KYIV,
LIKELY CIVILIANS, HE IS STAYING
UNDERGROUND OR UNDERCOVER TO
AVOID THE AIR STRIKES ON
UKRAINE.
ALSO, HEARTBREAKING SCENES.
>> A FAMILIAR SCENE UNFOLDS IN
THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
THIS PERSON SAYS GOODBYE TO
THEIR DAUGHTER AND
GRANDDAUGHTER, EVACUATING CITY
NEAR THE POLISH BORDER.
>> WE NEED TO LEAVE TO MAKE OUR
CHILDREN SAFE.
I NEVER THOUGHT IT WOULD BE LIKE
THAT.
IT'S NOT A JOKE.
>> LIKE THOUSANDS OF UKRAINIAN
MEN, HE WILL STAY AND FIGHT AS
THE RUSSIAN INVASION CONTINUES.
>> MY FAMILY, DAUGHTER,
GRANDDAUGHTER ARE LEAVING.
I AM STAYING TO DEFEND.
>> PEOPLE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME.
THERE'S A REAL UNDERSTANDING
THAT RUSSIAN FORCES COULD
SURROUND THE CITY IN A MATTER OF
DAYS.
A TRAIN STATION IN KYIV, THE
MAJOR EVACUATION POINT PEOPLE
LOOKING TO GO WEST --
THE CITY REMAINS ON EDGE
TONIGHT, WITH A CURFEW IN PLACE
AND ROADBLOCKS SET UP THROUGHOUT
THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
>> I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
ANOTHER CITY, WHERE THERE WAS A
LOT OF BRAVERY EARLIER IN THE
WEEK.
ONE OF THE SOLDIERS BLEW HIMSELF
UP TO STOP A RUSSIAN ADVANCED,
THAT RIDGE THERE.
THE RUSSIANS ARE THERE NOW
?>> YES, SO THE PART OF UKRAINE
NEAR CRIMEA.
IT'S SIGNIFICANT, ALLOWS THE
RUSSIANS TO CONTINUE THAT LAND
BRIDGE INTO UKRAINIAN TERRITORY.
WE WERE IN THIS AREA WITH THE
UKRAINIAN DEFENSE FORCES IN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE COUNTRY
ABOUT COKE, AND IT'S NOT VERY
WELL DEFENDED.
RUSSIAN TANKS AND ARTILLERY
UNITS HAVE MOVED QUICKLY INTO
THIS PART OF THE COUNTRY, BUT
WHAT IS SIGNIFICANT IS THAT IF
THE RUSSIANS CONTINUE THIS
ADVANCE IN THIS PART OF UKRAINE,
IT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO ATTACK
KYIV FROM MULTIPLE DIRECTIONS,
WHICH WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO
DEFEND.
>> Jesse: IF RUSSIAN FORCES
SURROUND THE CITY, WHAT KIND OF
PREPARATIONS ARE UNDERWAY INSIDE
KYIV TO PREPARE THE STOCKPILING
FOOD, WATER AND WEAPONS?
AFTER YOU ARE SURROUNDED,
NOTHING GETTING IN OR OUT.
>> Reporter: WE'VE SEEN IN
RECENT DAYS.
LINES ARE BLOCKED AT GROCERY
STORES, AND ALSO, AROUND THE
BLOCK AT POLICE STATIONS.
CIVILIANS PICKING UP ANY WEAPONS
THEY CAN FIND, GETTING READY FOR
THE RUSSIAN TANKS AND ARTILLERY
UNITS TO START ROLLING INTO THIS
CITY.
WHAT WE SEEN TODAY IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE USING ANYTHING THEY
CAN TO BLOCK THE ROADS.
THEIR CHECKPOINTS EVERY SINGLE
BLOCK, AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
CONCRETE BARRIERS, THEY ARE
PUSHING OBJECTS INTO THE STREET.
AT ONE POINT, WE SAW A PIANO
THAT HAD BEEN DRAGGED ACROSS THE
ROAD AND PUT INTO THE STREET.
HE GIVES YOU A SENSE OF THE
UKRAINIANS AND THE RESILIENCE OF
WHAT THEY ARE USING: EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO STOP THE RUSSIAN
ADVANCE AREA >> Jeanine: WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
40 MILES RUSSIAN CONVOY ENTERING
THE UKRAINE.
WHY IS IT NO ONE HAS ATTACKED
THAT CONVOY WITH A MISSILE?
>> THE UKRAINIANS DON'T HAVE THE
FIREPOWER.
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY DOES
NOT WANT TO GET INVOLVED AND
RISK THE RUSSIANS
COUNTERATTACKING, WHICH WOULD
TRIGGER ARTICLE FIVE OF NATO.
WHAT IS SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THIS
CONVOY: IT'S COMING IN THROUGH
THIS AIR BASE THAT JUST OUTSIDE
OF THE CITY LIMITS OF KYIV.
IT'S CENTRAL TO FIGHTING WITH
THIS VISION FIRST STARTED, BUT
NOW THAT THE RUSSIANS CONTROL
THIS AREA, THEY ARE LIKELY TO
START A GROUND INVASION AND
OFFENSE OF INTO THE CITY FROM
THE NORTHWEST.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, UKRAINIANS
ARE GOING TO BE HIT HARD.
IT'S PART OF THE REASON THEY ARE
HOPING THAT RUSSIAN FORCES DON'T
MAKE A QUICKER ADVANCE ON THE
CITY FROM OTHER DIRECTIONS.
THEY HAVE TO SPREAD OUT THEIR
FORCES, AND IT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY WEAKEN THE DEFENSE
FORCES HERE IN UKRAINE.
>> Jeanine: I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE DON'T WANT TO DO IT FROM THE
AIR TO THE GROUND, BUT ARE YOU
SAYING THERE ARE NO HELLFIRE
MISSILES, NO DRONES, THAT HAVE
TO COME FROM THE AIR?
>> Reporter: THEY HAVE DRONES
AND MISSILES.
THEY'VE TAKEN OUT A NUMBER OF
RUSSIAN UNITS ALONG DIFFERENT
CONVOYS, AND HAVE BEEN QUITE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE ANTITANK.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASON THAT ONE
OF THE MAIN REQUESTS FROM THE
DEFENSE MINISTER IN THE UKRAINE
IS MORE ANTITANK MISSILES.
ANOTHER POINT HAS TO DO WITH THE
SKIES.
EVERYONE THOUGHT THAT THE
RUSSIANS WOULD CONTROL THE
SKIES, AS THEIR AIR FORCE IS TEN
TIMES THE SIZE OF UKRAINIANS.
SO FAR, UKRAINIAN SUB-SHUTDOWN
FIGHTER JETS AND HELICOPTERS IN
THIS BATTLE.
>> Dana: I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE IS A NEW VIDEO THAT
WE ARE SHOWING ON THE SCREEN.
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT DAY TODAY
THAN YESTERDAY WITH THE
ADDITIONAL DAMAGE YOU ARE
SEEING, UNLIKE WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN EUROPE SINCE WORLD WAR II.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR --
>> Harold: FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR BRAVE
REPORTING AND BRAVERY.
WE HEARD THAT -- ANY SENSE OF IF
THERE IS AN ALTERING AND ASK OF
UKRAINE OR THE UKRAINIANS, LED
BY THIS GREAT PRESIDENT OF
THEIRS, GOING TO ACCEPT
SOMETHING IN LIGHT OF THE
PRESSURE THAT KYIV SEEMS TO BE
UNDER THIS EVENING?
>> Reporter: THERE WILL LIKELY
BE ANOTHER MEETING BETWEEN THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS IN THE
COMING DAYS, BUT WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER IS THAT
THE RUSSIANS OFTEN PROMISE
THINGS ON THE GROUND, AND THEN
ACT VERY DIFFERENTLY WITH THEIR
MILITARY.
WE SAW A STARK CONTRAST WHEN
THEY MET ON THE BORDER OF
BELARUS.
THE RUSSIANS SHOWED UP IN SUITS
AND TIES, AND UKRAINIANS, BATTLE
FATIGUES.
WE ALSO GOT MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE FRENCH, BECAUSE THEY
SPOKE WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN OF
RUSSIA, THE FRENCH PRESIDENT
EMMANUEL MACRON.
IT GAVE US A SENSE OF HOW
UNREALISTIC THE RUSSIAN DEMANDS
ARE.
THEY WOULD LIKE UKRAINE TO GIVE
UP THEIR WEAPONS, AND RECOGNIZED
AN AREA OF LAND ANNEXED BY
RUSSIA -- THESE ARE
NONSTARTER'S, AND THAT'S TRUE
FOR ANY PEACE PROCESS THAT WOULD
COME OUT OF THIS.
>> A COUPLE OF US.
>> >> Harold:
>> Harold: KHARKIV WASSURROUNDE.
IT IS BEEN SAID THAT THEY ARE
GOING WORK FOR CIVILIANS, GONE
FROM GOING OUT FIGHTERS TO
CIVILIAN TARGETS.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL,
KNOWING THAT THERE IS A 40-MILE
CARAVAN ABOUT 10 MILES AWAY FROM
YOU WITH THE SAME INTENTION?
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIANS
CLAIM THEY ARE NOT TARGETING
CIVILIANS IN THE UKRAINE.
IN SYRIA, YOU CAN SEE THAT
THOUSANDS OF CIVILIANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED BY RUSSIAN STRIKES.
IT'S PART OF THE PLAYBOOK TO
INSTILL FEAR IN THE POPULATION
AS THEY MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE
ATTACKS.
IT'S ON DON'T LIKE UNFORTUNATE
TO SEE THIS LEVEL OF HUMAN
CASUALTIES, AND SUCH A HUMAN TO
TOLL TAKEN, BUT THE REALITY IS
THEY ARE TARGETING CIVILIANS.
WE'VE NOT REALLY SEEN IT IN
KHARKIV, BUT HERE IN THE CAPITAL
OF KYIV OVER THE WEEKEND,
RUSSIAN MISSILES LANDED IN AN
APARTMENT BUILDING, KILLING AT
LEAST TWO PEOPLE.
THERE ARE AREAS SHOWN WHERE
THERE'S ONLY CIVILIANS.
IT'S PART OF THIS CAMPAIGN.
I THINK THE CONCERN, ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONCERNS WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER IS, AFTER
PRESIDENT PUTIN SLOWS THIS
OPERATION, AS WE'VE SEEN IN
RECENT DAYS, AND FACES THIS
FIERCE RESISTANCE, HE MAY RESORT
TO MORE CIVILIAN AREAS IN AN
EFFORT TO TRY TO BRING
UKRAINIANS TO THEIR NEEDS.
THE REALITY IS, THEY WILL FIGHT
BACK NO MATTER WHAT.
IT'S PART OF THE REASON THAT
YOU'VE SEEN UKRAINIAN LEADER TRY
TO GALVANIZE THE CIVILIAN
POPULATION AND ARMY AT THE SAME
TIME.
HE UNDERSTANDS THIS WILL BE A
FIERCE AND HEARTY BATTLE.
IT'S 3 MILES LONG.
IF IT MAKES IT TO THIS CAPITAL
CITY OF 3 MILLION PEOPLE, IT
WILL BE BLOODY URBAN WARFARE.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF DEATHS.
IT'S A HORRIBLE SITUATION FOR